ADAM MARTIN: All right, so
today, I'm trying something
different this semester.
I wanted to tell you
guys about one way
that you can discover
things in biology.
And this is going to fall in the
genetics cluster of lectures.
I want to show you how you
can go from being interested
in some property of an
organism, or even its behavior--
how would you go from
there to identifying
genes and mechanisms that
are responsible for that type
of behavior or appearance?
OK, so today, we're going to
go from some type of phenotype,
or process that you're
interested in, such as maybe
the appearance of an organism.
But we're even going
to go more abstract
than that because
at the end, I'm
going to tell you if you're
interested in behavior,
you can try to figure out
the genes and mechanisms that
are involved in determining
the behavior of an organism.
So the question is, how
do you go from something
you're interested in learning
about an organism to actually
identifying genes and mechanisms
that are important for that?
And on my title slide
here, I have three fruit
fly mutant phenotypes
that you can see,
and each of these
mutants defined
genes that were subsequently
found to be present--
or homologous genes
were present in humans
and were shown to play important
roles in human biology.
So later on in the
lecture, hall kind
explain what each of
these phenotypes is.
But first, I want
to just highlight
the importance of
model organisms
and their use in biology.
You've been seeing them already.
I've talked a bit
about flies, we
talked about
Mendel's pea plants.
I just now have a compendium
of model organisms
that I'm going to throw
up to tell you about.
So we've talked about bacteria
and the importance of bacteria
in elucidating the flow
of information from DNA
to RNA to protein.
Bacteria we're also extremely
important for elucidating
the initial mechanisms
of gene regulation.
I mentioned yeast a little
bit in the last lecture when
I mentioned tetrad analysis,
but we'll talk about yeast a lot
more later, when
we start talking
about the regulation of cell
division and the cell cycle,
because yeast played a
pivotal role in identifying
the gene that's critical for
this decision of a cell whether
or not to divide.
Also, one terrific
model organism in plants
is a Arabidopsis Thaliana.
And Arabidopsis has also
played an important role
in elucidating mechanisms
of development, but also,
in making advances in
scientific research that
relate to agriculture, such as
disease resistance and pathogen
interactions.
So the two heroes
of today's lecture
will be the roundworm,
Caenorhabditis elegans,
and the fruit fly,
Drosophila melanogaster.
But before getting into
study is in those organisms,
I wanted to highlight a couple
important vertebrate-model
organisms--
the zebrafish and the mouse.
And so you can see the
mouse is our lab mascot,
but it's also an
important genetic model.
In particular, there
are many models
in mice that mimic cancer.
And so these have been
useful for elucidating
mechanisms of cancer.
So it's really
unethical for us to do
a lot of different types
of experiments on humans,
but I will mention that
there are human cell
lines, such as the
HeLa cell line,
and these also play an important
role in biology research.
But these cell lines are
taken out of context.
They're not functioning in the
context of an entire organism.
So human cell lines
are important,
but you have to
understand that they're
sort of an in-vitro
system, that they're out
of the context of a
functioning organism.
OK, so why is it that we
research these model organisms?
So there are some
practical reasons.
Most of them are fairly
small, and they're
easy to house large
numbers of them in a lab.
They're often cheap to house
in the lab and work with.
Also, they develop fast.
And especially when
we consider genetics,
the rate-limiting step
in genetics research
is the time it takes
from the conception
of an organism to the time
that that organism can
reproduce sexually.
So these model organisms--
most of them reproduce
very quickly,
and so that accelerates
the pace of research.
But maybe most
importantly is the fact
that we are related to each
of these model organisms
through evolution because we all
arose from a common ancestor.
And just to highlight this
example, using the fruit fly,
the fruit fly has 17,000 genes
when compared to our 20,000
genes, so we have roughly the
same order of magnitude number
of genes as the fruit fly.
And so let's think
about important genes.
Let's think about
just genes that are
associated with human diseases.
If we just consider
human-disease causing genes,
75% of the human-disease
causing genes
have a homologous
gene in the fruit fly.
So we're similar to these model
organisms, such as the fruit
fly, in particular, genes that
are important for understanding
human disease.
So I came across this quote
when preparing for the lecture,
and I liked it.
It's from John Rinn, who
is a contemporary of ours.
And John Rinn said,
"Genetic approaches
are as fundamental to biology
as math is to physics."
And I think this is an apt quote
because both genetics and math
themselves are
scientific disciplines,
but they can be leveraged to
learn things about biology
and physics respectively.
So genetics really plays a
fundamental role in biology
and the discovery of new
biological mechanisms.
OK, so now, I want to just
briefly take you through,
how is it that we discover
things using genetics?
And I'm going to take you
through a type of approach
that's called a "forward
genetic screen."
And I'll get to the
orchestra in just a minute,
but I briefly just
want to define what
a forward genetic screen is.
So a forward genetic
screen is type of approach
you would do if you
don't know the genes that
are involved in a
specific process,
but you want to identify them.
So in a forward
genetic screen, you
don't know the genes
and mechanisms involved.
So you don't know
what these genes are.
You might not even have a
genome sequence of the organism.
You don't need a genome
sequence in order
to do a forward genetic
screen because you don't know
the genes, but you're interested
in a particular aspect
of development, or of
organismal function,
and you want to
identify the genes that
are important for that.
So when starting a forward
genetic screen, you have to,
then, infer what a possible
phenotype would look
like if you broke genes that
were involved in that process.
So the mantra of
geneticists is that we
are going to break genes
and then look at the result
and see if it gives the
phenotype we're interested in.
So in a forward genetic screen,
you're looking for a phenotype
that you would expect if you
affected a certain process,
if you disrupt a process.
So think about this
orchestra up here.
Let's say you are
interested in what
regulates each of these
sections in the orchestra.
What is the master regulator
of this orchestra, if you will?
And so conceptually, what a
genetic screen would involve
is taking hundreds,
maybe thousands,
of orchestras like this
one, and just shooting
an individual in this
orchestra, and removing them
from the orchestra.
And so let's say you remove--
let's say you remove
this guy right here,
then maybe nothing really
happens because they are, like,
30 or 40 other
violinists, and that's
not the major control circuit.
So then you would infer
that this gene is not
important for the
regulation of the orchestra.
But let's say you
took out Bernstein,
and then you listen
to the orchestra
and find that the sections
are uncoordinated,
the bassists start doing
crazy things on their own.
So then the logic of
Drosophila genetics,
you would then name
that gene uncoordinated
and infer that that gene
has some important role
in coordinating the different
sections of the orchestra.
So the goal in genetics is
to identify a mutation that
alters a gene function
that gives you a phenotype
that you're interested in.
And rather than taking
a gun and shooting
members of the
orchestra, in genetics,
you try to identify mutations.
So you try to induce mutations.
So we're looking for mutations.
And these mutations could
be spontaneous mutations,
meaning you didn't do
anything to induce it,
but they just appear as a
variant in the population.
And so we've talked
about Thomas Hunt
Morgan and the white
mutant, and the white gene.
So the white mutant was
a spontaneous mutation.
Morgan's lab didn't
do anything special.
They just looked at lots of
flies, and over the decades,
they identified this
one special male
fly that they could work on.
But nowadays, researchers have a
way to accelerate this process.
And so we can induce mutations.
In the way we can
induce mutations is
by using some type of mutagen.
So for example, you could have
some sort of chemical mutagen
that increases the error
rate in DNA replication,
or you could use radiation
to induce DNA damage,
and that essentially
accelerates the frequency
of mutations that occur in
the genome of an organism.
And so the process of
mutagenizing an organism
isn't specific to genes.
You're just inducing
random mutations
across the genome
of the individual.
Let's say this piece I'm drawing
here is part of a chromosome,
and these boxes are genes.
You're inducing
random mutations,
and maybe one mutation
hits this gene.
So that's a mutation
that might affect
the function of an organism.
You might have other mutations
that are outside genes
and may have no
effect, or you could
have a different kind
of mutation which
isn't in the coding
region of the gene,
but maybe affects the regulation
of this blue gene over here.
So this is a random process.
If you're feeding an organism
some chemical mutagen,
you're inducing random
mutations in different places,
and you don't know which are
the ones that you want until you
look at their phenotypes
and try to find
the needle in the haystack.
So let me show
you some examples.
So let's say we were
interested in our body pattern.
We all have a body.
Our head is in
our head position,
our ass is in our
ass position, we
have arms that are
in a right position,
our legs are in
the right position.
Let's say we're
interested in figuring out
what genes were responsible
for that body pattern.
What kind of a mutant
might you look for?
Anyone?
Rachel.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ADAM MARTIN: What's that?
A mutant with his body
parts in the wrong place.
Maybe you have like a leg where
your arm should be coming out,
or maybe you have two heads,
or something like that.
So you look for
some sort of defect
in the pattern formation.
And so this would be, obviously,
unethical to do in humans,
but in model organisms,
we can actually
find these types of mutations.
I'm just going to
highlight a couple mutants.
This one's an obvious one.
So this fly has two wings.
You can see them folded
over each other right here.
But there's a specific
class of mutant
that was called "wingless"--
where the flies have
fewer than two wings.
This particular fly
has only one wing.
And this wingless
mutant defined a gene
that became known as
wingless, and it's
a gene that has a
homologous gene in humans.
And this particular gene defines
an entire signaling pathway,
which--
whoops, sorry-- which is
important in stem-cell biology
and is also over
activated in cancer.
But obviously, we
don't have wings,
so this gene didn't get
discovered in humans.
It was discovered
in flies, and then
only later on, it
was inferred-- or it
was discovered that there
is a related gene in humans.
OK, so that's one example.
One of the other phenotypes I
showed you is called "notch."
Normally, a fly wing has
a nice, smooth margin.
But notch mutants have wings
that have this chunk taken out
of them at the end.
So again, the gene became known
as "notch" because of this fly
phenotype.
But again, there's
a human notch,
and human notch, again, is
involved in human diseases,
such as cancer.
OK, so that's two examples.
But now, I want to talk to
you about how one might find
the needle in the haystack.
How can you have
a concerted effort
to identify genes that have that
function in a given process?
I'm going to tell
you about work done
by Eric Wieschaus and
Christiane Nusslein-Volhard
because they did one of the
more famous genetic screens that
had been done, and they won the
Nobel Prize for their results
in 1995.
So I mean I take you through
this classic genetic screen.
In this screen, they're
going to induce mutations.
So I'm going to take
a parental generation.
And this screen was
done using fruit flies.
And they took male fruit
flies and treated the males
with a mutagen to
induce mutations
in the gametes these male
flies that would then be passed
to subsequent generations.
And they mated the
mutagenized males to females,
and then they went
on to look at--
to isolate individual
F1 progeny.
So we're going to
look at individual F1
progeny in this generation.
So in the F1 progeny
have the potential
to get one mutagenized
chromosome from their father
and will get a normal
chromosome from the mother.
So I'll just drawn
this like this,
where independent mutations are
going to be different colors.
So that has maybe a mutation
on one of its chromosomes.
Another fly, because
this is random,
might have a different
mutation on the same
or a different chromosome.
I'll draw a couple more.
And maybe one of these
flies doesn't have
a mutation that's been induced.
And then I'll draw just
one independent mutation
right there.
So again, this is random.
So to see random mutations, you
have to take individual flies.
Now, are you're going to
see a phenotype in this F1
generation?
So Miles-- is it
the Malik or Miles?
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: Miles.
ADAM MARTIN: Miles.
Good.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Most likely
not because any mutation
[INAUDIBLE] spontaneous
would be overshadowed
by the direct gene, the female.
ADAM MARTIN: Exactly.
So what Miles just
said is that--
basically, he said
that these mutations
if their loss-of-function
mutations are going to be
recessive--
because they're going
to be overshadowed
by a normal functioning gene
on the other chromosome.
So if you're looking for a
loss-of-function mutation,
that's likely going
to be recessive,
and you would not see
it in the F1 generation.
So in order to
look for organisms
that have incorrect
body patterning,
you need to get
a situation where
each of the mutated chromosomes
is homozygous recessive.
And to do that, you
have to do more crosses.
So what the researchers
did was to take
independent individual
organisms, and cross them all,
again, to non-mutated flies.
And remember, flies
don't self-cross.
So they need a male
and a female that
has the same mutated
chromosome mating to each other
in order to see a
recessive phenotype.
So because you only
have an individual fly
for each of these, you need
to get more than one fly
with the same mutation.
So they mate to a normal fly.
But now, you can get an F2--
multiple F2 males
and females that
will have the same
mutated chromosome.
So here, let's draw these.
They're still heterozygous.
At this point.
But at this point, you just
generated multiple organisms,
male and female, that have
the same chromosome that
arose from, essentially, the
same chromosome and the father,
or the male gamete and
the parental generation.
Oh, I did green.
OK.
OK, so now we have males
and females, both of which
are heterozygous.
And I'm skipping some of
the details of this cross.
You'll want to take
my word for the fact
that they can keep track of
which chromosome is which.
And I'm not going to tell you
how they did that because it's
fly genetics, and it's
not terribly important
that you know it.
So now, you have
males and females.
And now you can look an F3.
And from each of these lines--
each of these lines, you're
going to cross siblings
to each other.
So you're doing a sibling-cross.
What fraction of the progeny for
each of these sibling crosses
should be homozygous for
the mutant chromosome?
Yes, Steven.
AUDIENCE: One-fourth.
ADAM MARTIN: One-fourth,
exactly right.
So Steven's exactly right.
A quarter of the progeny
should get two copies
of the mutated chromosome.
So 25% should be
homozygous recessive.
And so you can screen
this F3 progeny
for each of these
independent lines,
and look for flies at some
stage of development that
are defective in patterning.
And so I'll show you how--
where'd my clicker go?
All right, so they're looking
for incorrect body pattern.
Yes, your question--
what's your name again?
AUDIENCE: Georgia.
ADAM MARTIN: Georgia, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Would there
be some [INAUDIBLE]
in the F2 [INAUDIBLE] normal?
[INAUDIBLE]
ADAM MARTIN: Yes.
So they're able to select for
the mutated chromosome, yeah.
And I'm skipping over how
they did that because it's
kind of esoteric.
But you're right.
Some would be normal.
But I'm just telling you
they're able to figure out
the ones that have
the mutant chromosome,
and they made sure to keep
those in the next generation.
Good question, Georgia.
All right, so they can
screen F3 for a phenotype.
It turns out all
of the mutations
they're interested
in are lethal,
so they have to look at the
larval stages for ones that
have a defect in patterning.
So this is what a Drosophila
larvae looks like.
And you can see it has a
segmental pattern here.
This is the head of the
larvae, the tail of the larvae.
But you see there are
these segments that
alternate between smooth
cuticle and hairy cuticle.
They have things
called "denticles,"
which are these hairlike
projections, which
are essentially, what the
maggot uses for traction so it
can crawl around.
So they're basically just
looking at maggots here
and looking at the pattern
of segments in the maggots.
But what they found is a mutant.
And here's a mutant
here which just
has these hairlike projections
all across the cuticle
without these intervening
regions of naked cuticle.
And because there's a lot
of hairlike projections
here, it reminded the
researchers of a hedgehog,
and so this mutant became
known as "hedgehog."
And the hedgehog gene
was the founding member
of an entire signaling
pathway, known as the "hedgehog
pathway," that plays important
roles in human development
and also, human cancer.
So the human gene
for a hedgehog,
or one of the most
important ones in humans,
is known as sonic hedgehog.
So you see that geneticists have
kind of an odd sense of humor.
But the sonic-hedgehog gene
is important in cancer.
And actually, there
are now a number
of drugs that are
being developed
to target the hedgehog pathway.
And one was approved
back in 2012 for use
in treating
basal-cell carcinoma.
And there's currently
another drug
that's in phase-II clinical
trials for treating
some forms of leukemia.
So this is a story that
goes from identifying
this weird fly mutant all
the way to clinical trials,
developing drugs,
whose purpose is
to inhibit this signaling
pathway, which hedgehog
is the signal--
the extracellular ligand for.
OK, so now, I'm going to
switch gears and tell you
about another story.
It's a bit like this one, except
this one has an MIT connection.
So I'm going to tell you about
work done at MIT in the worm
Caenorhabditis elegans.
And this work was
done in the lab
of Robert Horvitz, who is
a member of our biology
department.
And Robert Horvitz,
for his work,
won the Nobel Prize,
along with John Sulston
and Sydney Brenner
for their work
on how cells decide what
fates they give rise to.
And one thing that the
Horvitz Lab has done
is to elucidate the mechanisms
that determine whether or not
a cell lives or dies
during development.
So if we think about the
development of an organism,
we all start from a single cell.
And the cell divides
into different cells,
but different cells
in our body give rise
to different cell fates.
So if we consider just a
generic cell division here,
you have a parent
cell, A. It might
divide into cell B and cell C.
And maybe cell B might
have a particular fate.
It might go on to develop
into a neuron, or a muscle
cell, whatever.
It doesn't matter.
But one fate that Horvitz,
Sulston, and Brenner saw
is that sometimes, cells--
their fate was to just die.
And this was very stereotypical.
You get a death.
And this was defined as
"programmed cell death"
because it followed a very
stereotypic pattern, where
the same cell, each time,
would undergo cell death,
so it seems like there's
a program for it.
This also is called "apoptosis."
So what really enabled this work
is the biology of C. elegans.
And, here, I'm showing you
C. elegans development.
This is the C. elegans zygote.
This cell divides into two
cells that are different.
One is called AB,
one is called P1.
And we know exactly what the
fates for the descendants
of both these cells are based
on the work of Sulston, Brenner,
and Horvitz.
Now, you get a
four-cell stage where
AB divides into two cells,
and P1 divides into two cells.
And again, we know the
fates of all these cells.
And what C. elegans
researchers have
done, because C. elegans is a
relatively simple organism--
there are only 947 cells
in every individual worm,
so there are 947 somatic cells.
And this is stereotypic.
Every worm has these 947 cells.
How many cells do you have?
More than or less than 1,000?
You have more than
1,000 cells, right?
That makes you much
more complicated.
So really, the practical
aspect of C. elegans
is it has a much
simpler composition,
and they can track what
happens to every single one
of these cells.
They know when
every cell divides
and what the daughter cells of
that division will turn into.
In other words, they know the
entire lineage of this animal.
So this is a picture
of the lineage.
That's showing you what
happens to every single cell
in the development
of an adult worm.
And so what particularly
interested Robert Horvitz
is 131 cells, during the
development of this animal,
underwent programmed cell death.
And this is not
random cell death.
It's the same cells every time.
They know what happens to every
single cell in the development
of this organism, so they
know when there's a division,
and one specific cell dies
every time in the organism.
So it's really a
unique scenario,
where you can really see what
becomes of every cell that
is present in the organism.
OK, so now, let's talk a little
bit about the death process.
So I'll make the
cell-death process simple.
You start with a live cell.
So you have a live cell.
That live cell dies such that
you then have a dead cell.
And then after the cell dies--
after the cell dies, the
remnants of that dead cell
are engulfed by
neighboring cells, such
that you no longer
see that cell.
So the last step in this
process is engulfment.
Now, a key aspect of
one of Horvitz's screens
is that other researchers had
identified a mutation that
affected cell death that
specifically blocked
this engulfment process.
And this gene is called ced-1.
There's the first cell-death
mutant that was identified.
"Ced" stands for
"Cell Death abnormal"
so C-E-D is short for "ced."
So researchers in
the C. elegans field
started isolating these
cell-death-abnormal mutants,
where something happened in
the cell-death process that
was abnormal.
And I'll tell you how this was
leveraged by the Horvitz lab
to identify, basically,
a pathway of genes
that were involved
in cell death.
So this is now a worm.
And what you see
in this worm are
these bubble-like
structures that
are cells that are dead
but haven't been engulfed.
So these dead cells, because
they're not engulfed,
are visible in the adult worm.
And so you can basically
just look at adult worms,
and see whether or not these
bubble-like structures are
present in a ced- mutant.
In a wild-type worm,
you don't see this,
and so it's harder to see.
But this provided a
visual assay to look
for mutations that block
the cell-death process
because if you block the
process upstream of ced-1
in an engulfment, you
no longer will see
these bubble-like structures.
And so that is what
the Horvitz Lab did.
They started with
ced-1 mutant worms.
So they're starting
with the ced-1 mutants.
And they then mutagenized
these ced-1 mutants.
Sorry-- mutagenized.
And so they're essentially,
looking for second mutants
in this animal that will
affect the death process.
OK, I'll take you through
the logic of this.
So for the remainder
of the generations
I'm going to tell you about,
they're all ced-1 mutant.
Ced-1 is homozygous,
in this case.
And the worms are
hermaphrodites,
meaning they are both male
and female sex organs.
And therefore, they
can self-fertilize.
So this is a self-cross.
And so ced-1 remains
homozygous mutant
throughout all these crosses.
Now similar to the fly screen,
they can look for individual--
or you get individual
worms here.
Let's get some colors so we can
compare different chromosomes.
All right, so this chromosome
might have one mutant,
this chromosome could
have another mutant,
and this chromosome could
and maybe this one
doesn't have a mutant.
OK, but again, these are
heterozygous animals,
so if you're looking for
a loss-of-function mutant,
you would not see the
phenotype at this stage.
So what was done in this screen
is, because these are worms
and they're hermaphrodites,
they basically
allowed each of these
worms to self-cross.
So now, were talking
just about a self-cross.
And because a single worm has
just one of these chromosomes,
when it undergoes a self-cross,
a quarter of the progeny
will be homozygous
recessive for the mutation.
OK, so here, we have
the F1 generation.
And now, they can just
look at the F2 generation,
and they're looking for some
fraction of the worms resulting
from each individual
that has a phenotype that
looks like a cell-death
mutant phenotype.
And so they're
essentially, going
to screen through
the F2 generation,
and look for worms
that fail to have
these bubble-like structures
in the adult world.
So they're looking for a loss
of these refractile structures.
And they got one.
This is now a double mutant
between ced-1 and ced-3,
and you see how
you no longer have
these big bubble-like
structures in the worm.
So they identified a
mutant, and thus, a gene,
that's called "ced-3," which
basically causes a failure
of the cells to
undergo cell death.
Now given what I've given
what I've shown you,
is this necessarily a mutant
that's involved in cell death?
Can you think of an
alternative explanation
for why you would lose these
sort of bubble-like structures?
What else could be happening?
When you do a screen
like this, and when
you do science in
general, you have
to think through all
the different types
of possibilities.
Yes, Georgia.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ADAM MARTIN: Excellent.
Georgia said you could
have re-mutated ced-1.
So one possibility is that you
isolated a ced-1 revertant,
which means you changed its
DNA sequence so that now,
the ced-1 gene is functional.
So one scenario
here is you could
have some type of revertant,
or you could have a suppressor
mutation.
Maybe you have a
mutation that bypasses
the function of ced-1
such that now, the cells
can engulf the dead cell.
So you could also
have a suppressor.
Or the alternative scenario,
the one that we want,
is that we've affected
the cell-death process
and identified something that is
a bona-fide cell-death mutant.
How would you differentiate
between these two?
Any ideas?
Should this have an extra cell?
No.
Stevens says no.
I agree.
There should be
no extra cell here
because if you restore
the phagocytic process,
then the cell should die,
it should be engulfed,
and there shouldn't
be an extra cell.
But if this is a bona-fide
cell-death mutant,
then you should
have extra cells.
And it turns out the
ced-3 mutant blocks
all 131 of these cell deaths so
that you have 131 extra cells.
Because they know the entire
cell lineage of this worm
and can see whether or not
cells are present or not,
they can tell if there
are extra cells or not.
And therefore, that
allowed them to infer
that they had an
actual mutant that
was affecting the mechanism
that promotes the cell to die.
And this shows that
the cell death--
it shows the cell death
is an active process.
It's not just some random
event that's happening.
It's an active process that
is controlled by genes.
So there's an active mechanism
involved in the cell death.
Any questions about how these
screens go in the crosses
before I move on?
OK, so I have one more
story to tell you about,
and this relates to behavior.
So now, I want to tell
you about behavior.
We all behave, some of
us better than others.
So how is it we can
go from something
as abstract as behavior to
specific genes and mechanisms
that control this?
And I'm going to tell you about
work that was awarded the Nobel
Prize last year.
Two of these researchers--
their careers are at Brandeis.
And so what they discovered
is the mechanism that controls
circadian rhythm in organisms--
so circadian rhythm.
So circadian rhythm
is a behavior.
We are awake during
certain parts of the day
and are asleep at night.
If you're hidden from
the light-dark cycle,
you continue this cycle
for some amount of time.
So there's something
intrinsic in our system
such that we want to exist on
this 24-hour wake-sleep cycle.
That's why it's
a pain in the ass
to travel to the other
side of the world.
So we want to identify what
controls this behavior.
What, then, might be a
phenotype you might look for?
What would happen if you
break circadian rhythm?
Yeah, Rachel.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ADAM MARTIN: It wouldn't have
a nice, clear wake-sleep cycle.
Exactly.
So this screen--
what they did is
to look for flies
where they didn't have
this robust wake-sleep cycle.
So you basically look for
flies that are awake at night,
and identify the mutations
that cause this to happen.
OK, I'll show you an example
of what the data looks like.
So what each of these
lines is each tick mark
is a measurement
of fly activity.
So what you see are flies
asleep, they're awake,
they're asleep, they're awake.
And researchers
identified mutants that
didn't show this 24-hour cycle.
So some are just
totally arrhythmic.
Other mutants alter the
period of this cycle
so that it's either
longer or shorter.
So this is a really
elegant way to look
for genes that are important
for circadian rhythm.
And I'll take you through
the genetic screen.
This was done by
Konopka and Benzer.
And they did a nice screen.
It involves a genetic
trick which I'll show you.
There's a type of chromosome
called "attached-X" in flies,
where two X chromosomes
are fused to each other--
so two X chromosomes fused.
And if a fly has two X
chromosomes, it's female.
If it just has one X
chromosome, it's male.
So that's determines fly gender.
So then these researchers took
males and mutagenized them.
And they crossed these
males to attached X females.
And when you cross males
to attached X females,
you do something clever,
which is half of the progeny
dies because you
need an X chromosome
and you can't have
three X chromosomes.
But your females
are all attached XY.
So the females actually
get their X chromosomes
from their mom, which is the
opposite of the way it normally
works.
And males get their
X chromosome from dad
because the attached X
strain has a Y chromosome.
So this is a little
bit of a genetic trick.
And the fly-- the reason it
was done, in this case, is they
wanted to mutate
the X chromosome
and then have the fathers
pass on their X chromosome
to their sons because there's
only one copy of the X
chromosome.
So if you get a
mutation on X, you
don't have to homozygous
it because there's
only one copy of it.
So it's a little bit of
a genetic trick that,
in this case, served
the researchers
a generation on their screen.
OK, so you take this, and
then you identify males now
that have a mutated
X chromosome,
and they have only
one X chromosomes
so you should be able to
observe the behavior even here.
But to establish a line of
flies that have this mutation,
they then took these
F1 mutated males,
and crossed them, again,
to attached X flies.
And again, in doing this,
all the males from this cross
are mutant.
So now, you have multiple
males, all of which are mutant.
So you can start with
a single male F1.
And by crossing it
to this strain here,
you get a lot of males now that
have the mutant chromosome,
and you can look
at their behavior
to determine whether you've
affected circadian rhythm.
Does everyone understand how
the attached X works here?
It's kind of a little
bit of a trick,
but flies have these
tools that you can use
to save your time in the lab.
OK, so these mutants that
the Benzer Lab identified had
altered period of
the sleep-wake cycle,
and therefore, the gene
was named "period."
So this screen identified
a gene called "period."
This is a gene.
And there's a hammer log of
the period gene in humans.
And the gene in
humans is associated
with familial advanced
sleep-phase syndrome.
So defects in the genes
that were identified
in Drosophila actually are
relevant to human sleep
disorders.
All right, I'm all set.